- Sir, do you recognize me?
Last week you sold me
bogus Jason Mraz tickets.
That's a BS!
How do you feel knowing
that the whole world
knows you run a Ponzi scheme?
That's a BS!
Illegal pizza delivery.
I don't remember
ordering this topping.
That's a BS.
Tune in Monday to find out
which telemarketing firm
I call BS on.
- Hey grandma, it's me Ricky.
I'm selling magazines
for school again.
So I was wondering if I
could have some money.
- Old people are so stupid
(laughs) wisest generation.
Oh, cool!
- We should start beating
up old people too.
- Right?
- Just 'cause I
hate 'em so much.
- Remember, you
can't BS Miss BS.
- [Anchorman] Well, Chuck what's
going on with the weather?